what you really want to see
is black wall street
you want to see the greenwood district
thriving with hundreds of black owned
businesses lining the streets of
greenwood
however much of the property today does
not belong to
african americans it's a gift to be able
to say you come from such
amazing people and that you're on the
grounds of what used to be
something the world had never seen
before i've always felt the connection
to black wall street
and to rebirth it the tulsa massacre of
1921
destroyed nearly 200 businesses in the
area that came to be known as black wall
street now entrepreneurs and activists
are pushing to carry on its legacy
they're advocating for more black owned
businesses and property ownership
amid gentrification that's reshaping the
historic black neighborhood
the greenwood district of tulsa oklahoma
was once a center of black wealth
in the early 20th century located north
of railroad tracks the divided tulsa
during segregation
it was home to thousands of black
tulsans and their businesses
but in 1921 white mobs attacked the
district
killing dozens of black residents and
destroying about 35 square blocks
over the course of one night researchers
say the damages filed in court cases
decades ago
total over 22 million in today's dollars
but this likely underestimates the
actual losses as not everyone had full
insurance coverage or went to court
after the massacre black entrepreneurs
worked to rebuild greenwood
but local historians say the district
went through a decline
as desegregation led to outward
migration and urban renewal programs
displaced black-owned businesses and
residents
today greenwood consists of about four
city blocks
there's not much housing stock in the
neighborhood and just over two dozen
black owned or operated businesses
remain registered with the greenwood
chamber of commerce
the historic groomer chamber of commerce
owns the last
10 buildings known as black wall street
um
we house 33 businesses 31 of them are
african-american
so we're still doing what our ancestors
did
it might not be black wall street but
it's definitely a black main street
and so we have to preserve this while
there's a growing number of black-owned
businesses in this district
some of the newer establishments are
tenants in buildings owned by white
developers
that's a reversal of fortune from 100
years ago when many of the property
owners were black
the massacre destroyed real estate
assets that could have been passed
to future generations
our oldest living survivor daddy clark
died at 109 years old he was a teenager
his
photograph is on exhibit in the gallery
tulsa residents like michelle brown
burdeks
say it's important to keep telling the
story of how prosperous
black residents of greenwood were before
its decline
we were never taught that african
americans were
business owners that they were pilots
and electricians and doctors
and attorneys and i was shocked
that we had never learned about this
being born in tulsa being raised in
tulsa attending black history
classes brown brudex coordinates
educational programs
and tours for the greenwood cultural
center we thought
that this was the perfect time in the
spirit of black wall street
to identify and promote black-owned
businesses
in our community as the city
commemorates the centennial of the
massacre
brown brudex has teamed up with a local
co-working space and incubator
to create a guide of black-owned
businesses in the area
when we first began this work many
people were opposed
to us even acknowledging or recognizing
the history
of black wall street or of the massacre
now as we approach the commemoration
there is much more support
it's clear things are changing again in
the greenwood neighborhood
a different museum called greenwood
rising is among the construction
projects
redefining the look of the area
it's a challenge because some of our
work
is quite similar but we are
finding ways that we can complement
one another as opposed to competing
with one another oklahoma state senator
kevin matthews who heads the commission
overseeing greenwood rising
says the museum is working with
organizations throughout the historic
district
to tell the neighborhood story in
cooperative ways
still brown berdex says her vision for
greenwood remains the same
personally i would love to see more
black owned businesses in the greenwood
district i would love to see
home ownership increase in this area
after being displaced by urban renewal
projects decades ago
many black tolsons now live in the
city's north side
this is my home this neighborhood i grew
up in
tyrants billingsley ii a tech
entrepreneur recently learned about his
family's ties
to the rebirth of greenwood in the 1930s
what i know was little but i do know
that my direct descendants
were cousins of people who helped donate
to vernon amy church and help rebuild it
billingsley is now looking to carry on
the spirit of greenwood in his own way
the actual district of greenwood
obviously is being heavily gentrified
i like to think of greenwood as two
different things the body is the land in
and of itself
and then there's there's the spirit or
the breath the breath of greenwood is
the spirit that black
entrepreneurship the the sense of
community the breath of greenwood is
very much still alive
billingsley is spearheading a project he
hopes will bring opportunities for
today's black tulsans
to create the kind of generational
wealth seen decades ago on black wall
street
black tech street is an initiative to
rebirth black wall street
as the premier black tech hub here in
tulsa currently in its beginning stages
one aim of the project is to weave
coding and other applicable skills
into after school programs for black
children
billingslea says he has about 1 million
dollars in verbal commitments
and is working with partners to
fundraise we have a goal of facilitating
one billion dollars worth of investment
in this community over the next 10 years
you know around six strategic pillars
entrepreneur support
narrative and communications capital
workforce
infrastructure and policy
other black entrepreneurs are interested
in rebuilding wealth in this area
but some black tolsons say the city must
do a better job in reconciling with its
past
to protect the area's black institutions
and businesses
i want it to be so that an endowment is
set up
so that these buildings are maintained
and that economic development
can be fostered hopefully
undoubtedly we will have a conversation
we will see some type of real
reparations
take place black wall street as it was
in 1921 prior to the massacre and it
as it was once it was rebuilt in the 30s
and 40s and
50s may never be again but black wall
street
is an idea i
appreciate the businesses that are here
in the greenwood district
and then we have the greenwood cultural
center we
remain here telling the story we are
actually looking forward to
the next 100 years